I'm gonna roll it into a log roll in
Ibiza
he's from Romania it's kind of like near
the Middle East right I Drive by little
Armenia all the time and it smells
amazing on Anoosh Leaney I love any food
that can be the adult version of a
Lunchables sort of like a meaty fruit
leather looks like my tongue this is
something that I would want to have with
like a beer a very subtle spice hmm oh
the leg that makes it you have to have a
little it kind of reminds me of ketchup
fried rice that my mom made as a kid to
each his own
why can't more things be delivered on
little leaf spoons that taste like it
came right off the nipple it tastes like
salty water down yogurt I could dip a
cucumber in this and just go all day one
would expect something that looks like
this to either be sweet or taste like
milk
yes neither this looks like a zesty or
mashed up matzo ball soup
I like how gentle the broth is just a
whisper it feels like I'm alone in a
bathtub reading a good book does it not
do you eat soup at the tub what kind of
mood is
ah I like that a lot of this food has
been like Lokar this is like the
ultimate fuel good food I feel like
every culture has something that they
want when they come home on a fall day
dude I know pizza and this is pizza look
if I came home from school and my mom
had made me this I would just be like
yes yeah mom lock mizune baby it's more
peppery hmm yeah the pepper the meat the
lemon the onion its demands to be roll
back my pinkies need to be up for this
you know
this is kind of like the sweetness that
I'm used to because in Japanese cultures
it's like very also subdued sweetness oh
good
oh it's warm it looks like Donald
Trump's there
Oh quite possibly the most delicious
thing I've ever tasted okay like I'm
eating a sweet hair ball to to3 cannot
cannot cannot cannot it tastes like what
it smells like to walk into a Christmas
store all my organs are tingling
what's the strength of my arms ooh and
it's like opened up my nasal passageways
man Armenian people like party am i
right I've lived throughout the Middle
East and I love Arab culture there's a
lot of overlaps I've really enjoyed it
it's all something that you would gather
over a big table and just share and have
a good time with oh man there's no weird
stuff it's meatballs in soup this could
have been baklava but then you could get
in a completely different way and you
have something that tastes just as
amazing and a completely different like
flavor palate